hello everyone and Merry Christmas
everyone I didn't really have time to
prepare a game for you like I usually do
but I decided since it is Christmas I
will at least share one a nice puzzle
with you I don't remember the exact time
I saw this puzzle but I remember this
one instance I was probably at a
tournament somewhere with Yun Almighty
and we were driving from the tournament
or to the tournament can't really
remember and I asked him to solve this
puzzle but I asked him to do it
blindfolded I only said the position to
him I told him the king is there a
bishop is there pawns that the rook is
there and he had to solve it and it took
him like a couple of minutes but he in
the end he did saw the position and we
had a really good laugh so this is one
of the one of the puzzles that I really
find interesting and its really it's if
you've never seen it it's a pretty
amazing puzzle and you'll really feel a
lot of joy after you solve it so this is
the puzzle I do invite everyone to try
and solve it give it a couple of seconds
pause the video and really try to solve
this it's white to win really try try to
win it any way you can there is there's
actually a very nice win but anyway you
can win it it's it's perfectly fine so
pause the video and try to do it for
yourself so we'll give it a couple of
seconds as usual okay you know just in
case you want to decide what we want to
pause the video for those of you who who
were able to solve this I congratulate
you very a very nice job it's it's quite
the puzzle I always enjoyed when I see
this puzzle and for those of you who
maybe weren't able to do it or maybe
didn't have enough time to study it for
yourselves the idea is you have to play
rook to h6 and this is the only move
that actually wins the game now as you
probably if you try to solve it you you
probably notice that black can't really
move the bishop now we have to rook to
h6 if you move the bishop to pretty much
any square white will simply play rook
captures an H 7 and this checkmate on a
seven-story in this is checkmate and if
you try any other move for example
if you don't move the bishop let's just
bring back the pawn here after rook to
h6 you might want to try and capture
drug that's probably the only other
reasonable choice after you capture the
rook white place b7 and this is
checkmate now so this is this is the
solution to the puzzle
I really hope most of you were able to
solve it if you were able to solve it
you know be be sincere write in the
comments I was able to solve it or
hashtag salt or anything I just wanted
to share this one with you guys hope you
all have a very joyful and Merry
Christmas and as as of tomorrow I will
see you very soon as usual so as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
I think all for watching and I would
like to thank Kent Stefan Eric Wilkinson
Jackson Novotny John Anthony turbos and
Matthew Dickinson for a contribution to
my channel thanks a lot I really
appreciate it thank y'all for watching
once again and I will see you soon with
a lot of videos as usual thank you